Okay and that's all I want to show you about in,
inheritance, and in fact that is all I am going to
show you about templates. So just remember that templates are, a
great way to separate different types of code. You can keep your
HTML separate from your python for the purposes of this class,
which will make your life a little bit easier I hope.
At least your code a little more clean hm. Make more
readable code, better organized code is
more readable. Make more secure websites.
You know, if you use the autoscaping feature of Jinja
or other template new languages you dont have to worry so
much about putting, you know, insecure malicious data into your website.
And finally, you know, you have HTML that's much easier to
modify. Instead of trying to manipulate strings in python you
have HTML in your HTML editor. It's much easier to manipulate.
So if you want to learn more about Jinja you can go
to this URL, to learn more. And the slots of documentation
here and there's all sorts of nice little escapes
and filters and convenience things that can make the templates
more and more powerful. So thanks for listening so
far and I hope this helps you in the future.